Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
says he expects president Trump's
nominees for Secretary of State and CIA
director to have quick confirmation
hearings Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson who was fired yesterday said
an emotional thank you to the State
Department employees the president chose
CIA director Mike Pompeo to replace
Tillerson he also wants Pompey owes
deputy director Gina Haspel to lead the
CIA she would be the first woman in that
job but there are concerns about her
role in the agency's aggressive
interrogations Jeff Pegues is on Capitol
Hill where the issue is likely to come
up during hospitals confirmation
hearings Jeff good morning good morning
it is are links to waterboarding that
have really shadowed her rise to the top
of the CIA and already some members of
Congress are signaling that they might
try to block her confirmation I've
already made it clear that Senate
Democrats like Ron Wyden are already
preparing for a bruising fight over Gina
Haspel and Mike Pompeo nomination and
the partisan rift is visible Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
both these nominees seem perfectly well
qualified but questions of torture
continued linger over how spells past
after September 11th the veteran CIA
officer was one of the officials
presiding over a program that led to the
use of waterboarding and other harsh
tactics on al Qaeda captives she later
helped carry out the destruction of the
videotapes of those sessions
intelligence sources say she was
following the orders of her boss at the
time Jose Rodriguez I got approval to do
this in the show time CBS documentary
the spy masters he explained his
thinking my primary motivation in
destroying the tapes was to protect the
people who work for me a spell was
ultimately cleared of any wrongdoing she
did exactly what her job was and she did
not do anything wrong former acting
director of the CIA Michael Morell
worked with Haskell at the agency for a
decade I do not believe that this will
be an issue in a contra
as a 33 year veteran of the agency has
spell supervised covert missions around
the world and served as a deputy
director of the CIA over the past year
every job she's had that I know of she
has performed in an outstanding way on
the campaign trail in 2016 then
candidate Trump seemed to endorse
enhanced interrogation tactics no date
has been set for hostiles confirmation
hearing but when it begins you can bet
that she will be peppered with questions
about whether she will comply with an
order to restart the program Dora
alright Jeff the gaze thank you